have you ever seen like someone who's in
the public spotlight and you don't see
him for a while then they come back like
what what happened correct you know I'm
glad you brought this up you know I have
a bone to pick with and I celebrate his
music
maybe it's an Australian thing if Keith
Urban doesn't stop wearing foundation
and putting highlights in his hair I'm
gonna bust but not a cool way I'm gonna
bust my fists on your face so I'm so
glad I'm so glad you brought this up cuz
mad at him why does he do that because
what's your foundation on his face I'll
say this you might be very talented
never less like yeah never liked to hang
out in our group because you're too vain
well no hope lazy could you heart and
suck a dick that's the vibe I get yeah
we have foundation like that and then he
has these highlights yeah I mean again I
love our streaming fans you guys tell me
is that cool out there right now
cuz here you're gonna get Rosie's
wearing I might as well walk in listen
to limp Biskit yeah and [ __ ] what
yeah in affliction shirt yeah why sir
why do you have highlights in your hair
you little oil perfectly done yeah and
they as foundation oh my god apparently
it's not enough to kill the people after
a while there to eat them gotta start
eating them gotta start first well then
that's what's happened between eating
and killing what is it sex nope you got
a drink well you have such their bodies
and they're dead yep but you also drink
their blood
mm-hmm yeah Vampira they just static
secure their urge like gets worse and it
never goes back apparently the the
urology you can reset it gets worse
professional sports far as UFC or box
and goes but as far as you know getting
hit in the head or jumping off the ring
and then you know the concussions cuz
how many concussions have you had no I
will say that in my career [ __ ] I might
have had maybe three another one time I
got dropped on my head maybe an errant
chair shot or something I always put my
hands up cuz I was smart enough to put
my hands up so that wasn't an issue for
me to me really you know and like guys
have different styles and I was more of
a pure wrestler trying to clone Rick
flair because he was my you know he's
the greatest of all time I tried to
emulate his style when I when I created
the ultimate body of work I did that as
Stone Cold Steve Austin it was more of a
stand up
so that was my system you got some of
these guys who you would consider
cruiserweight guys you know your 200
pound there's 210
you know 180 and at vane and they do all
this you know that stuff so those guys
are more you know closer to be getting
you know concussions and stuff like that
when Daniel Bryan told me he had you
know 15 whatever it was you know as all
the missile drop kicks when you're
landing on the damn mat it's not like at
and you're taking that bat move is
taking more out of you than the guy you
gave the missile dropkick to so I always
tell people if you got a shitload of
concussions other than the cruiserweight
style you were doing something wrong
because the buck is supposed to be at
work yeah you know if every time you go
out you get concussed you're into its
upright like it's Brendan if you go out
every time you go out boom you get
knocked out inside of one minute you're
doing something wrong yeah I think I
retired [ __ ] change yeah yeah because
what when I think people think out you
know they know what's coming this is
scripted stuff like that when you hear
the schedule and that stuff like when
you're on the road what happen how many
days of the year
check us out I was thinking about this
the other day I'm glad you had me on
your show I was singing because someone
was talking about the business I think
it was that one time when Connor was
rolling up everybody in the WWE he said
some yeah sweets to him whatever a lot
of guys just restarted you don't even
and responded to her I was like man the
dudes arrest and fan from way back yes
and he's a great fighter and I love to
watch him I'm looking forward to see who
fights out the one and two coming up on
UFC 209 but I tell you it'd be like yes
if anybody in an MMA world or a UFC
world or whatever and got no respect for
the business of pro wrestling or just
just a lifestyle in the brutality of it
I would invite you to take your training
camp to a different town and reign in a
different town every day just like a WWE
people do just follow them around
training different camps every single
day then go home on a couple days that
we give you and then get back on a road
take that training camp and get ready
for a big ass fight when you throw the
travel at it and you
got no policy of 5 to 10 15 people
taking care of your asses just you
running solo go do that yeah and then do
it for 10 or 15 years and then report
back to me because I want to see what
the science and I'll talk to you about
what the [ __ ] we do yeah no I hear you
man come on oh yeah come on I'll take
your Pepsi challenge don't like to roll
with the polar bear okay because until
you now you don't understand this but
Brendan would you don't understand what
I'm about hangers out of my face
Brendan work when you understand when
you're actually in a fight yeah and that
second sense kicks in and Brendan is
Brendan so [ __ ] at home with it look
at them cross-legged drinking a [ __ ]
mocha or something yeah life taste the
taste of death when someone you've never
been punched yes I have and you're being
super distracting those and you taste
that iron of your own blood something
else turns on what turns out that's
right man wait yes there's a
fight-or-flight there is a
kill-or-be-killed
instinct that happens okay and no no
thing we'll teach you that instinct and
put it inside you like a polar bear
I believe it so much it doesn't drink
anymore um not that I ever had a problem
with it no no actually you know you know
me yeah I I would either get good and
pissed or like not drink for months like
I don't care oh now I want to get drunk
with my pals so alcohol I never really
you know was good at drinking I don't
think I was a happy drunk thing just not
my thing I enjoy good scotch and good
tequila I haven't had it in around five
years but back in the day I was at a
thing I was at this comedy event in
Canada and I was with my good buddy
Timmy O'Halloran whom I've known for
many years and we read this thing in
London Ontario and we got really drunk
the night the big bash at the end of
this Canadian comedy awards festival
thing and then we had to drive
they gave Timmy Oh a Canadian Tire van
with nothing in the back just two seats
up front no heat and he we drove London
to Toronto I think cuz we missed our
sedan or something it was pretty great
so here's me and Timmy oh and I'm very
hungover and we went to the McDonald's
because you want some McDonald's I was
like yes it was like 4:00 p.m. like I
finally staggered out of that room
before and that we went up and he goes
and it's what would you like to order I
was like give me just give me a number
four with a supersize it with a diet
coke so like some like quarter pounder
meal or something like thing and he goes
okay number four with coke diet coke and
I'll take give me a give me a number
three with sprite and then I go okay and
then give me a give me a Big Mac - okay
and a Big Mac and two cheeseburgers and
two cheeseburgers fillet a fish one just
do you want to fillet a fish no I don't
want to play fish to fillet fishes to
fillet a fish would you have some
Nuggets if I don't want Nuggets would
you have some no if I order them no you
won't have even one because I want
Nuggets get Nuggets then you want six
Nuggets no do you want some I don't want
any if I get 20 Nuggets will you eat
some nuts well don't get 20 Nuggets I'm
paying I want 20 Nuggets if you you have
some I will not have one I will not have
a Chicken McNugget I'll just get you ten
ten chick 20 chicken meat with ten just
20 chicken McNuggets find 20 chicken
McNuggets and it went on like that to
where he was like giggling like just
order the [ __ ] menu just get one yeah
and an apple pie and blueberry pie and
hot fudge sundae no nuts that's it and
it was [ __ ] hilarious and so I ate
all that and then I feel sick as [ __ ]
yeah then we pulled over down the
freeway I don't know what beautiful
Canadian freeway that was and I pissed
and then puked all over the side